hey canada lily how's it going i'm good
how are you doing
really good i know going into this that
you had said that whether
it's the performance or exec producing
role that you wanted people to see you
as something other than betty cooper i
personally think you nailed it
how do you feel about that i think i
mean i don't know
it's hard for me to to even begin to
guess how people are going to react to
the film i would hope
positively i would just hope that people
who are already a fan of mine
from riverdale can watch the film
without any pre you know without any
preconceived notions they can
lose themselves in it and discover this
new character
um rather than seeing me as as as betty
i guess
is that why you wanted to do something
so different i mean she's still it's
it's still high school there's still you
know drama and heartbreak and everything
else but it's on a
it's just not a different level this
hits just so different than anything
that i've seen you do before
yeah and that was that was on purpose
you know i really wanted to do something
that felt uh like in a different world
and and obvi i never want to play the
same character
twice that's boring my job is to play a
part to play a character
and so there's nothing fun about playing
the same character twice and although
you know i'm very happy that i play
betty i love her
um but i also really love playing new
characters and exploring that
and so getting the opportunity to play
grace
who is inter you know
introverted she's not being the leader
by any means she's going through
uh a traumatic event that she's kind of
keeping very private keeping to herself
kind of not letting people in very close
that was such an interesting um
thing to play you have such a fantastic
relationship open relationship with your
fans and you know what it's like when
you're young
when there's heartache or tragedy or
breakups
you gravitate towards music and you
gravitate towards movies what is it like
for you to know that you've created a
movie
for those young fans who are going
through things like heartache
and breakup and tragedy this is the
thing that they will now you know
hopefully gravitate towards to help them
out
and i hope so i think i yeah there's
nothing you know if i'm
i watch the movie her by spike jones
when i when i'm really like
in my feelings because it just it it
almost validates it's very validating i
think
you you turn to poetry you turn to music
you turn to movies because you want to
be validated you want to know that
you're not alone and what you're feeling
and i think this film for young people
and
people of any age can hopefully watch it
and and feel
a sense of they're being seen they're
being heard like oh i've experienced
this i've
i've been in that position where i've
wanted someone to
to to get better or to change or to be a
better version of themselves for my own
self
and i think that's something that all of
us can relate to in one way or another
so i just would hope that people can
watch this and and feel comforted by it
and what is life like i know that some
shows are going back into production and
some sets are opening what is what's
happening with
what's happening with the show are you
back to work yet do you know
yeah we do we are my neighbors are
jumping on the trampoline
um uh i am going back to work
this weekend actually so i'm traveling
back to canada
to start my quarantine before we start
shooting season five
so we're going up we're getting ready
incredible
well it's going to be wonderful to have
you back across the border
and uh it was great talking to you your
movie's really beautiful and i can't
thank you enough for this
thank you i appreciate it take care